it's not going to put you out of
business but let there be no confusion
it's happening right now and in 2 years
you all know four or 5 years ago I'm
yelling screaming Tik Tok and nobody's
listening everybody was chilling in
Instagram if at all and then Tik Tok
happens and a lot of people regret not
going hard when I yelled about it four
or five years ago not because they're
out of business but because they left a
lot of money opportunity Happ maybe a
change of career or building something
around there was just a land grab of
opportunity that's how I feel about this
AI thing a lot of people here can have
dramatically more efficient sales
organizations you could drive down your
cost by 50% and Forex your Revenue why
wouldn't you you could keep doing it the
way you're doing look I have to go home
now I could take a train or a horse they
used to I'd prefer to take a plane and
so that's what I think is happening here
like this is about understanding how
profound these technology movements are
and understanding like the only thing
holding you back is a subjective opinion
or ideology that you're holding and I
think that's bad business
strategy